murder
is a crime that is very very
simply defined
it uh happens when a person commits an
act that causes the death of another
person and the defendant or the
perpetrator acts of what we call malice
of forethought which is simply defined
as an intent to kill some murders are
spontaneous they happen quickly without
much thought
a typical example is a bar room fight
two guys go to a bar to have a good time
one disrespects the other and two
seconds later a bear stein is being
slammed into somebody's head and kills
okay there's no opportunity for any real
uh deliberation or premeditation in that
act you're going to have a default
second degree murder unlike these
circumstances where mr holder had plenty
of time
a full 10 minutes passed
after that conversation in the time he
returned and committed the shooting and
we know in that time he prepared his gun
he armed himself with a second gun and
all of the facts that i've discussed
earlier this morning
plenty of evidence of premeditation and
deliberation again it does not take a
long time for meditation and
deliberation is not measured by how much
time somebody spends thinking about
a cold calculated decision to kill can
be reached very quickly
the law recognizes that in this case you
have quite a bit of time
for premeditation and deliberation
10 minutes is a long time to think about
something and then do it
now this instruction here heat of
passion and this is where the defense is
going to argue to you
that this cold blooded this cold and
calculated killing should be mitigated
and the theory that you're going to hear
is it should be mitigated because nitsy
hustle himself
provoked mr holder
to attack him
that nipsy hustle did something
that was so powerful
it caused an almost irresistible
response in mr holder to kill
that's what he to passion is that's how
it's defined in the law the target is
nipsey for sure that's what he really
wants but he's got to account for the
other people who are there
and that's why he shoots them
he doesn't shoot them by
accident he doesn't
bullets aren't passing through nipsey
and going into other people
he's pointing bullets fly straight he's
pointing the gun and he's hitting who he
can
he sides it up from the time he turned
that corner and walked along that
sidewalk in front of those storefronts
and carried out his plan to a t
was able to do all of this damage and
escape aid him back down to long beach
for a couple of days safely